Of course it will depend on which cities
were talking about.
Um,
I think that we will see variations
between different parts of the world and
different parts of the United States.
I would,
my prognosis is that the biggest game
changer in the future of cities by 2050
will be the technology at the moment,
which is rapidly erupting in
connectivity.
Um,
you know,
and often it often occurs to me that a
lot of the travel that we do in our
current environment is not travel that
we really want to do.
It's because we work somewhere distant
from where we live.
And I would like to think that in the
cities in 2050 generally,
each area of a,
a large city,
it will become more community based.
So there'll be a lot more options for
people not to have to move around in the
first place.
So rather than commute 20 or 30 miles
across a big city will have the
opportunity to do a lot of our work.
Maybe not all of it,
but a lot of our work quite close to
where we live,
uh,
that we need to get away from the idea
that we live in large dormitory areas.
And then we have all of our work in
industry and a office space and another
area.
There are plenty of good examples of how
you can mix a mixed the zones up and
still make a very livable and enjoyable
environment for people to live in.
So rather than a commute being a couple
of hours out of every day,
uh,
maybe a commute means just a couple of
minutes.
Ooh,
that's more difficult to,
that's more difficult to say.
I think if the human race is still
around in a hundred years,
uh,
it means that we have,
we've been hung very much over the edge
of the cliff and we have,
we'll have got good at a lot of things.
I think,
uh,
I think even maybe by 20,
50,
uh,
I mentioned it a little before,
we will probably be moving goods a lot
less and food we will be needing to grow
a lot of the food and the goods that we
consume.
Uh,
we need to produce that much more
locally to where we live rather than
divorcing it from the cities need to
become more integrated.
And the same with work.
Uh,
I think that would be far more community
based.
In some ways it will require us to,
to go backwards a little.
Maybe it will be living in smaller,
but at the same time,
much more desirable living spaces.
Uh,
we will,
I mean,
it's just,
it's so difficult to predict what
technologies will have available.
And I'm in 90 years time,
it's difficult enough in 50 years time,
but so it's really difficult to say.
So if we've got cities and 2100,
uh,
makes me very optimistic that we'll be
still around,
we'll be,
if we're still around,
it means we figured out how to do a lot
of things much better than we're doing
now.
Yeah.